this is a real Temptation in our culture
you're seeing this right now from Mr
Dylan Mulvaney probably one of the
greatest examples of it who has had he's
the he's the transvestite who was a
Broadway actor and then he pretended to
be a woman and and on Tick Tock every
single day he says that's day five of
being a woman and um today I'm flitting
around as a sort of a caricature of what
a woman is I've cried 10 times today
I've never felt more like a woman well
Dylan Mulvaney has had some surgery to
make his face look more like Bruce
Jenner's and now he is posting videos
saying that he looks super duper hot
stay 335 of being a girl and I wanted to
go on record to say that this might be
the hottest I've ever looked and will
ever look in my lifetime
and I'm making this video so that in
thousands of years there will be
evidence is it the dress
it could be the dress it is it the
makeup or is it the hair because I think
it's the extensions and when I have
extensions in I don't know my name I
don't know where I live I just know that
I love these and I know that I look like
I could steal a husband but I want to
promise you look me in the eyes I want
to promise you that I would never do
that to you okay I am a girls girl and I
love ya
whew but seriously this is good right
okay okay okay love you love you okay
uh uh much much to say about that video
because it's not just Dylan it reflects
a lot of the problems in our culture
Dylan Mulvaney has just given the best
proof yet
that transgenderism broadly or at very
least the type of transgenderism that he
suffers from
is a sexual fetish it's what the
psychologist Ray Blanchard called Auto
gynophilia
uh Ray Blanchard the psychologist said
that there are two kinds of people who
think that they're the opposite sex
there are homosexual transsexuals who
are attracted exclusively to men
and are feminine in both behavior and
appearance and then there are Auto
gynophilic transsexuals who experience
sexual arousal at the idea of having a
female body
it would appear
well Dylan Mulvaney might have
he might have a little touch of both I
guess but but he certainly has the
latter
inasmuch as he is viewing himself as a
hot sexual object he's saying I've never
looked hotter in my whole life ladies
and it's a funny line and he's saying it
with the dead pan of a trained actor
but
it it does prove the point he's saying I
am looking on my body that some surgeon
has constructed for me with lust
and then
he goes further and he says when I'm
looking at me in my hot new body in the
mirror I don't know my name I forget who
I am I forget where I am all I know is I
just think these hair extensions are
really hot
all of this is an admission of what
conservatives have said about
transgenderism from the beginning which
is this is obviously a sexual fetish
and this is obviously an expression of
self-hatred
that's what he's saying he's saying oh I
just feel such relief I'm so happy
because I forget who I am I'm so happy I
forget my name
I just forget where I am I'm escaping
from a reality that I don't want to
confront into a fantasy and a delusion
that that is relieving my sense of
contempt for for the real world and also
arousing me sexually it's just a total
Vindication of what the conservatives
have said the lips have said no no
transgenderism is just it's just who you
really are it's just people living their
true lives authentically and loving
themselves Dylan Mulvaney's saying no no
way man I hate myself I want to forget
who I am I don't want to know my own
name
I want to forget I forgot I want to
forget where I am I don't I don't want
to remember anything about the real
world
I just want to pursue my sexual desire
to a state of a kind of sexual ecstasy
that's what he's saying he's saying
we're right
and and we have been right about this
the the self-hatred problem is a big
problem very often the the culture of
body positivity or love yourself or
Pride which is the Primal sin the queen
of all vices and the vice of all queens
is my friend Andrew Cleveland has
pointed out uh is a mask for self-hatred
very often the people who are most
boastful who seem most narcissistic and
egotistical paradoxically they also are
filled with the most self-hatred you're
seeing this reflected in
all of the popular culture but look at
this cartoon that we played last week or
the week before proud family which is a
reboot of a 20 year old cartoon a proud
family has been rebooted to push BLM and
woke intersectional leftist
nonsense and to push onto a culture of
predominantly white people the sense
that white people are evil
how do you understand love don't you no
no I do not understand anything about
white fragility my virginity
what's that supposed to mean you know
what it means you're doing it right now
you're doing what being defensive about
race Robert D'Angelo wrote a whole book
about it read it yet again
cover and everything
my dad wouldn't even look at the diary
he said his people would never own
slaves how could he just dismiss me like
that white fertility oh brother Kwame
white fragility that's what it is
now it would be very easy
to say that all of this anti-white
propaganda is just a problem coming from
black people or from non-white people
that's not primarily what's going on
all of the anti-white if you're if
you're a little boy and you're white
you're evil you need to apologize for
your whiteness
that stuff is largely coming from white
people
it's it's not so simple as to say Hey
you radical black people need to stop
pushing this on this is it's largely
white people the book that they
referenced is by Robin D'Angelo Robin
D'Angelo is a white lady
the people who run these networks
pushing all this stuff are by and large
white people
and it's white people who who want to
hate themselves I'm I'm very lucky I
don't know maybe I got a vaccine when I
was a kid or something I am completely
immune to white guilt maybe it's because
the Italians are a sort of racially
liminal people always been a little bit
ethnically ambiguous so I just I just
don't feel it at all
I feel the shame of my sinfulness I feel
a healthy fear of Temptation because
this is a fallen world and we're all
born with original sin though I feel
confident that that won't that won't
destroy my life and send me down to
Perdition because one's soul is cleansed
in in baptism that's that's kind of my
view of the whole problem but for for
the modern liberals
who ignore that who ignore True Religion
who ignore the wisdom of the ages and of
Revelation who it's not that they become
much more
empirical and grounded in their views
they actually became much they become
much more Fantastical and superstitious
in their views they they can infer
and into it that something is wrong
about this world they they recognize
that there is such a thing as original
sin they just don't want to call it that
so they've got to call it something else
they recognize that something is wrong
with themselves but they don't they
don't have any path toward Redemption
and so it just leads them further and
further down this pit and they blame it
on their skin color they blame it on
whiteness or they blame it on their
their
sexual expression they blame it on an
alleged conflict between their gender
identity and their sex so they chop
themselves up and they mutilate
themselves and they they do that
spiritually and they do that physically
in the case of Dylan Mulvaney and it's
all
it's all just a road right down the pit
there's no there's no getting out of
that it's just it's just more and more
self-hatred compounding on itself
[Music]